I'll lock so what's a crab opening
here's something I found on the web
according to Chicago Tribune calm the
happy crab is a cheery of anonymous
Chinese leaning seafood spot in
Greektown mm-hmm seafood wait let me go
will this crab over new crowd opening
chest
the crowd warning
although we're open what so we're a four
oh so this oh like a crab like ah that's
what crabs do right I guess that makes
sense
I'm tired of sea animals got stung by a
stingray earlier today
oh that sounds undesirable I found I
found a crab so this is like the the a
pond and this is H pond so I either have
to play I guess if I'm white I'll try
and play crab and if I'm black I'll try
and play AG room fouled I feel like
those are the most opposite openings
like one super serious theoretical
approved by MV l and fiddler and the
other Ridge is named after seafood
playing fool down oh so do I play the
crab or the bong cloud I haven't not
played either yet this is Rea this is
rated rapid I think the crab is probably
slightly better than let's play the
crowd I feel so bad playing this playing
the crowd
okay now now we're reverting to serious
chess I did I did the crab thing crab be
happy and now it's it's chess time how
to justify this probably this move I
have some some kind of opening yeah this
is like a delayed scandi down a tempo
where I've committed to a four in each
four I guess I'll try and justify it
huh I'm realizing like if I take and c5
happens like I can't access either of
these squares which are usually the
squares I want to access so I think I'll
deal with Knights and then just try and
develop
okay c5 well does this c5 probably good
move let's move back
développé I really can't complain with
this I'm getting development we each
have two minor pieces developed I'm
controlling some interesting squares
with Myra pons
I feel so crab like the problem is these
squares are a bit more weak because
these pawns can't move backwards I guess
no crab is perfect
that's a really annoying move because I
don't want to lose this pot but I also
don't really want to play this or this I
guess I can play be three there's queen
bee for Queen d2 or Bishop d2 life will
go on
the plan is just to like develop things
and get the King safe hey it's Jake
happy Sunday Rosen thanks for solving
for two months yeah happy Sunday
appreciate that
I'm playing fool down we played once
before vaguely remember this game so
cool down is searching for a revenge
alright that move makes me feel less
threatened
it's like if I throw an a5 I guess box
and just take it there's night g5 which
is interesting
I was also debate do I move my bishop in
which square do I move my pleasure to
hmm
at first I was thinking Bishop here but
then I don't know if I want to trade it
off so let's develop it this way
have to mesh my time
time to crush Satan crush dition aha
yeah I'll try and do whatever that means
I am in good shape to attack like the H
pawn the H pawn serves a purpose of like
trying to scare away black from calcium
Kings side a pawn does the same thing on
the Queen side black castles anyway now
the question is do I actually have
anything I guess I should complete
development
I'm hesitant to castle because I kind of
want my rook staying behind the H pond
so I might end up just playing like King
f1 kim ji-won
but I guess we'll see
let's play this the attack is brewing
Alexa tell me a crab a pun
what does a crab call his ex what is old
bay
hahaha like bay wait
Oh like chess Bay or like ocean bay
uh-huh alright not sure not sure how
that compares to the crush station crush
tation pun that was better or worse
maybe for a decent move yeah I was kind
of scared of this but
do crops fuel fear
not sure
Alexa our crabs capable of feeling fear
here's something I found on the web mmm
according to cnn.com love those crabs
okay I guess that answers my question
but not really let's play see three Matt
CNN two very reliable source okay look I
can move back
maybe this move yeah
- this move
again the attack is still brewing I want
my bishop to return to d3 this will be
like the the head or the heart of the
crab this will be the claw this is other
claw all their claws not really doing
much but I'm feeling I'm feeling like an
optimistic crab
I'm wondering if I can just leave my
night there just leave my night there
crabs don't really make well-thought-out
decisions do they they just rely on
instincts and try and snap away all I
want to do is open the H file there's
some kind of Bishop h7
there's a crazy line takes takes naive
or takes takes takes of g6 Bishop e5
writing mates and then takes takes and
I'm still threatening meets and then I
guess f6 but then I take it should be
winning for whites
yeah the ball is in box courts
the other day I went to Trader Joe's and
I bought could have blocked crab cakes
but they're vegan crab cakes so I don't
think they have real crab but it was
like crab list crab cakes they're
delicious
oh we might be going into this line too
ooh or not
well it's Tom silver Marco Polo
thanks for the bits
Marco bits so there's a weird line here
can the skein get weirder Bishop h7 King
f8 Bishop g8 and if King takes G I think
of Queen hundreds h7 and I'm eight I
can't resist I can't resist it's too
much fun
Bishop GE a coming let's go wait doesn't
do anything though you might not do
anything but it's so much fun
there's a smooth to
oh it's so close to mate there's a crazy
line bishop g6 takes rook here oh I
guess there's bishop GA I was
calculating king f7 Queen takes King
takes Knight h4 King f7 g6 Don King f6
I'm not quite working I have this move
this move is nice
that's a simple move to
I like that move yeah the crowd is
snapping away I'm down the piece ooh
look at this
it's a c4 crowd okay
so many crab crab terms or associations
I don't know this is looking really fun
though
I think blocks actually kind of in
trouble obviously I'm threatening me
than one I'm not sure what block does to
stop it and it's raining really hard but
the power better not go out I just need
the internet to survive for just a few
more minutes Alexa tell me a fun fact
about crabs here's a fact about crabs
hmm
according to Wikipedia in some species
crab meat is harvested by manually
twisting and pulling off one or both
clothes returning the live crab to the
water in the belief the crab will
survive and regenerate the claws by
making it a sustainable industry I don't
know if that was a fun fact or just a
traumatizing fact g6 alright let's take
a bishop
how what does this move
oh that's a very clever move that was
really clever I can take this so but
coulis my opponent for finding that the
brain is tiny smaller than the point of
a pencil hmm Zenden thought maybe it's
just a fact
all right let's fee in color the queen
threatening threatening me than one
again during two different meats in one
that was not the move I was expecting I
was expecting d4 that's probably
playable if I take
I just want to like sack a queen even
though it doesn't work at all
it kind of looks fun I guess we gonna
have to trade bishops we trade yeah
let's trade we're not too many other
options can trade again it's interesting
let's try it again and see what black
does giving black a choice here yeah so
that's actually the move I was hoping
for but I'm not entirely sure if I can
punish it it's not using Queen f6 takes
takes King g8
and then I mean I have to play like g4
g5 let's go for it
we're entering a new stage of the game
called the endgame but it's also blitz
now as opposed to rapid we're both below
three minutes times close to two even I
don't think I'm scared of this it was
King e2 maybe I am scared I don't know
93 Keaney to metaphor this could be a
mess oh I looked away at the chat and
now there's all this debate about like
diets yeah this is kind of hard to
follow
okay I'll focus on the game and let's
focus on probably getting in some g5 if
I get in g5 then all I need to do is
teleport my rook from a1 to h8 and these
plans will be very stable there's
actually a really cool position okay
let's not lose a rook Oh
rook seen ones coming on play rook be
one if rook c1 I I take you can then 94
and the Knights kind of stuck
93 might be coming I'll start with this
okay well it was a failed arrow
I was really weird barrel like large
there for a moment yeah I want to draw
it from from p1 to h4 so the way to get
there is via b4 I can't play trick
before immediately because this 94 might
happen or rookie for
all right let's play rook I guess rook
age three
have to be very careful I'll handle this
I'm just gonna bring the King to g2 that
this should be good enough
and blocks very long time and probably
getting mated or maybe not yet
okay here we go wait it's still not
working because rookie four it's so
close though something in 95
doesn't quite work actually let's go for
this yeah I've at first I saw a truck g4
King f1 rook c1 but now I'm realizing I
have 91 and this is this is finally
winning I believe okay the crab has been
a success don't mess with the crab
thanks for the game fool down
apologies for playing a slightly
insulting opening but a very lovable sea
creature oh yeah people in the chat show
your love for the crab was it YouTube
worthy I don't know if I should analyze
so much the scheme it was an interesting
game though this was a fun position and
the funny thing I didn't even make this
this comparison this is a fishing pole
trap but I don't know who was fishing
was the crab the one fishing or was a
crowd caught but then resurrected I
don't know